finally all of us together for the world
to see what we are capable of you need
to get out of here let's let's get into
glass a little bit talk about where this
film picks up in terms of how long after
split how long after unbreakable are we
meeting all of these characters to
choose the split exit it's pretty close
it's a few few weeks two to three weeks
after the events of split has taken over
so 15 16 years from the unbreakable
timeline on on screen so very direct
connection to split and you know salmon
James how have your characters evolved
since the last time that we saw them
I'll start with Sam it's been a minute
since we've seen mr. glass and so who is
he when we pick up with him this time
around same guy his thought processes
are better the same he's even more
dedicated to what he believed before
just buying this time being facing James
what about what about it's it's been a
shorter period since we've seen him but
so who is he when we pick up with them
they were there
I think the hordes are more galvanized
there's more of them 11 of them I think
when we pick up and near in the
ascendancy and they're very much in
control I think there's less conflict
within the group there's more concerted
drive towards you know executing there
one of you get in their world view
spread out there in I know a lot of the
other person I know you created more
personalities for split did you use some
of those personalities that you had
created for split and didn't use and
split in this one or are they all new
yes no we if you see in the computer on
and split you'll see all the
personalities all 23 not counting the
beast 24 but then on the glass we
figured all of them out all 24 what they
were what they meant to be and I believe
23 20 are in the movie now which is
pretty incredible that's got a its
enhances sort of the performance that
you split with all those characters he
can't answer I don't know he is
absolutely jaw-dropping for me you know
unbreakable and split
I feel like have different tones to them
unbreakable character drama character
study split to a certain degree a
character study but also kind of plays
like a kidnapping thriller so what what
is glass is it a combination of those
two tones is it something different yeah
I would say that's a pretty accurate
depiction it's it's you know Eltham
Utley I think you'll feel it was a
fusion of a comic-book movie and a
thriller that those two genres were
brought together and hopefully even an
even balance but there's a lot of drama
I mean it's really about family members
about you know this this version of the
comic book world these three movies as
much much about them and their
relationship to their family members and
how you know what what it's like if you
really had these powers if you thought
you did and the implications on you on
your family that means it's a graphic
novel is not a comic book
I think that's pretty accurate you speak
about family you know unbreakable is
very much about a hero and his
arch-nemesis but it's also such a
powerful story about a father and a son
and it does that relationship sort of
materialize more and evolve and ingress
yeah and in particular we had Joseph his
son played by the same actor Spencer and
Spencer is now 30 years old I so it was
wonderful to see the same character and
you do see I don't give too much away
but you do see moments of the original
unbreakable that you seems you didn't
get to see oh so that's cool so yeah
you'll see it from a bridge yeah you
haven't seen and you'll see the same
actor change you know 18 years on
on-camera in front of you which is
really powerful oh yeah and you it's
rare for a movie to be a boyhood and
things like that where you really watch
them change over a phone you know and I
look at a breakables watching it and you
know you have a comic book you have
century man sort of facing on this
against this beast is what were you
thinking about these kinds of
confrontations back in unbreakable of
sort of the beat yeah you know action is
not my sweet spot it's not where I go
when I think of how I want to tell a
story so then it needs to be the action
needs to be an extension of the
characters and what it
so somebody fighting somebody is always
difficult for me I hate you I hate you I
hate that that's difficult but I'm
stronger than you you know oh wait I'm
starting to doubt that you know
wait no I'm gonna I know I'm definitely
stronger than you like those kind of
character movements when we talk about
what the characters are feeling in the
scene is important to expect and
especially what he's trying to
accomplish in the movie when you see it
you know with these two individuals
David Dunn and Kevin Lang no problem
right oh well guys I wish you all the
luck in the world on class thank you
[Music]